by his
real first name
all right we are officially live episode
number 84 with phil heath adam and
gerard so it's been it's been a minute
no
it's been a minute by the way you guys
look very friendly right now just a
minute ago off camera you and gerald
were about to fight
uh yeah well it started with phil
who was instigating that's the question
always amazing
somehow i could somehow don't see that
well i just don't see that question
pressing the buttons right he's pressing
the button i just said good morning
philip and he looked at me like
who though
you think you are
well address me by my real name phil
and then gerard piled on we waited for
you
by the way i think it's fair to say from
the last time we did podcast till today
a lot's changed a lot of crazy things
man david can we raise my audio a little
bit more if you don't mind i know you
guys want to lower it but raise it a
little bit more
vanessa and david are not in the mood
today everybody's out it's just them
they're lonely there you go much better
we got a lot of crazy things that
happened last week yeah okay a lot a lot
of things that happened last week
uh last night we're at the where my
office you can come down last night
we're in my office we're preparing for
the podcast thank you caroline last
night we're at the office and
uh
we started talking about
guns
we started talking about god gerard's
favorite topic we started talking about
religion we started talking about
history we started talking with gerard
said things kind of feel a little out of
whack
and that led to a great conversation
where we were all holding back because
we wanted the podcast to be honest
we said
even though we kept saying we kept
saying let's keep it for tomorrow 20
minutes
let's keep it for tomorrow so we can
talk about it today anyway so we've got
a lot of topics let me go through a few
of them that we have here today
one of them is is faith uh at its
highest or lowest in america today
including the world and is the world a
better place
when a country is ran based on a
religion or not you can debate that
we'll debate that today have a good
conversation about it
uh uh it's gone is that a good invention
who did it help the most we'll talk
about that adam's very excited about
that one
elon musk says universal basic income
we need universal basic income because
in the future physical work will be a
choice you know this whole robots he's
building he's got some interesting
things to say about that chinese
authorities say over time 996 policy is
illegal tom brady this uh avows
today's work ethic saying it's not how
to live a joyful life says
seven time yeah
super bowl champion
in his mid 40s
joe rogan confined to spotify's losing
influence it's an interesting article
with some data there celebrities
disappear from internet as china moves
against fan culture china limits online
video games to three hours a week for
young people biden admits administration
his administration may have given the
taliban kill list of afghans who aided
u.s
staggering costs u.s military equipment
left behind in afghanistan special op
veterans carry out
secret pineapple express mission to
rescue 500 afghans and australia created
a police state to stop covet 19. data
shows it's not working folks if you're
from australia let us know if you're in
australia right now like you're living
in australia right now comment we'd like
to get a caller in from australia i know
you got somebody else as well if you get
a hold of it maybe we can do something
with it let's start off with the
equipment kai do you mind pulling up
what equipment is left behind
in uh afghanistan with the taliban what
is left behind so
is this the article or is there one that
shows all the different uh
you know which one i'm talking about the
image
okay let's take a look at this let's
take a look at this so what are we
looking at here
vehicles and airplanes is this uh so we
got 42
ford ranger pickup cargo trucks are left
behind
22 000 humvees ambulance cargo troop
enclosure gun truck variants left behind
8998 medium tactical vehicles i was a
mechanic for those vehicles but they
call them lmtvs or fmtvs
five-ton cargo and general transport
truck
thousand five recovery vehicles i was
licensed to do that and operate those uh
they're great to drive by the way you
can run over trees at six so a thousand
five of those left behind 928 mr ap max
pro ambulance combat left behind 189
armored personal carriers left behind in
other words tanks keep going down that
76 000 right there by the way here's the
pricing
armored personal carriers such as the
m113a2 cost 170 000 each the
m57782 cost 333 000 each mine resistant
vehicles range 412 to 767 each total
cost would range around 382 million to
711 million dollars keep going over to
the next category on what we got okay
here's the helicopters 111 helicopters
60 transport cargo airplanes
we got 20 light attack airplanes 18
intelligence
reconnaissance and surveillance
airplanes go a little lower that's 208
there what's the price on those by the
way let's look at some of the prices
there
427 million dollars of uh the blackhawk
helicopters each cost 21 million dollars
okay each keep going lower i mean the
taliban one right here if you look at
what they got keep going lower to the
next part is there any other equipment
okay here we go
rifles
three oh my goodness
5330 m16s
m4 carbine ak-47s
and sniper rifles
that's 358
000 there's only 75 000 taliban by the
way
358 126 000 pistols m9s and g19s
you got 64 363 machine guns 25 327
grenade launchers 12 692 shotguns 9877
rocket propelled weapons
2 606 indirect fire weapons that's 599
weapons
okay go a little lower kai
what's the total number i saw 85 billion
dollars oh we got more stuff here
sixteen thousand nine vision goggles two
120 radio monitoring systems 22 ground
anyway so that's another 16 000
equipment keep going lower and lower and
lower is there anything left at the
bottom anything left that we have at the
bottom
the total number was what 85 billion
dollars give or take
85 billion dollars of equipment the
taliban got what do you think about that
gerard
well when you leave behind uh
a billion dollars in military-grade
assets
civilians and allies i think it's pretty
bold and audacious to consider it
leaving afghanistan that to me sounds
like a retreat that sounds like
submission that sounds like we retreated
from afghanistan we left people
but we left our people and our property
behind that doesn't also mention needs
to be shouted out the the dogs that we
left behind that are being
cared for by a civilian who stayed
behind an american civilian who was
behind enemy lines right now and an
afghan ally and they're both
volunteering uh so once again the
private sector picks up where government
drops the ball but um
this just gets uglier and uglier and
uglier by the day and as it came out um
you know you did a great uh interview
last week about how
they're trying to paint this as first
they tried to paint it as we were
completely taken by surprised by this
then uh general miley came out
earlier last week and said well this was
inevitable we knew it was going to
happen
and he you lead by taking the troops
first they don't take their equipment
okay
uh and and this and not to sidebar too
far but this isis k stuff it drives me
out of my mind
this used to just be the mujahideen and
we supported the mujahideen when they
were anti-russia and anti-china then it
became al-qaeda in the taliban and we
had to go in and get them because of
al-qaeda but then we became allies with
al-qaeda in syria because they were
anti-assad so we couldn't call them al
qaeda anymore they were rebranded as
isis we rebranded them and now it's now
it's isis k so we have both been allies
and enemies with the same group for 20
years
and what have we gotten for it what have
the american citizens gotten for it
nothing we got nothing out of this all
right we got pain and suffering for
people who were willing to risk their
lives and now all i heard and this is
something republicans messed up 20 years
ago all we heard was we got to protect
our freedoms gotta pretend i have still
yet to have somebody explain to me well
how we needed to protect our freedom six
thousand miles from our shores
i don't understand what we were doing
there in the first place and but since
we were there i don't understand how we
could leave like this
i i mean sam harris to his credit or one
of the foremost liberal thinkers in the
world
tweeted out i am he retweeted himself he
tweeted on january 20th after the
election i am overwhelmed with joy uh to
have adults back in the room and he to
his unique meaning elaborate meaning
biden but the biden harris uh troika all
right and to his credit he retweets
himself
publicly eating these words syllable by
syllable
and that that's where we're at right now
so kudos to you sam harris kudos to to
bill maher kudos to to the other
liberals who refused to go down with
this sinking ship but uh as a country
and this is something you know that the
more conservative listeners are not
going to like i look at nikki haley i
look at donald trump jr who i find
hilarious and they're piling on to make
sure that you know that this is biden's
fault this is by dude
we know
i need solutions thank you how are we
getting people out of there what are we
doing now that we just gave a billion
dollars to people who want to do us harm
we know who to point the finger at all
right but when you point a finger at
somebody else there's three pointing
back at you right phil you one point
pointing that way three pointing this
way
somebody anybody in our political
geosphere but here's the question for
you put solutions out there please
fine so what does he do what does junior
do
well he's in sales right now he's
selling he's selling that biden's
incapable in the car but no no what i'm
trying to tell you is okay so imagine
the average voter writer that's
listening to this yep they're pissed off
who isn't pissed off today
cnn's pissed off because alyssa milano's
not pissed off well let's see molasses
not pissed off but she's who is alyssa
milano in the first place she's the
cousin vinnie is isn't that's the one or
no that's where i said something okay
that tells you how much i know about
this
she's one of those okay i mean i know
her face if i see amanda but here's a
point okay take alyssa milano out
everybody else who isn't pissed off
today cnn is pissed off because he
biting is making them look like idiots
okay msnbc is pissed off because what
they
were his campaign it's like hey we want
this trump guy out
uh fox is pissed off because you know
they're seeing what's going on because
they're pro-military everybody's pissed
off who isn't pissed off but the average
person that's listening to this
what can they do about it what can the
average guy do about it what can junior
do about it what can what can they do
about it what can all these guys do
about it so the only people that can
really do anything about it is who
the people in charge the people in
charge so no matter how much you put it
on anybody else i'm sorry it's like dude
i'm not in charge what do you want me to
do you can scream off the top of your
lungs you can do all the things that you
want to do but what can you do this
takes me into what pineapple express did
that's the part where you brought up and
said pat this entire time people are
thinking we have to rely on somebody to
do something this is a group of
civilians that are like listen dude we
don't care we're not waiting on you
we're going to go out there and do this
right you want to unpack what happened
with those guys so the listeners can
kind of yeah so for people that don't
know there's a bunch of ex-veterans
they're uh they're no longer active duty
or the ones that are active duty refused
to
identify themselves obviously because
they pretty much broke international
treaties and they they committed an act
of war by invading uh a sovereign
country but really these are guys that
were on uh that did multiple tours in
afghanistan these are special forces
guys that got sick and tired of waiting
for the government to get their allies
and people who helped them people who
helped save their life their lives
translators particularly in their
families uh out of harm's way so they
just went in they said screw it we're
not waiting for clearance i mean this is
like a 1980s like like arnold
schwarzenegger movie this is like
predator this is like hardcore old
school
america is the best
movie stuff here but these are real guys
who went in and they saved between 500
and a thousand people they got them
across the borders out of afghanistan
and and uh we'll never know who they are
because obviously they're they're
technically war criminals now but these
guys are heroes we know how some of them
are because they talked about it a
couple of them a couple of them came out
and flat out they talked about it and
tim kennedy apparently was very uh very
very um big in organizing it and and uh
he's just stuck
that guy's a frickin stud you know tim
is a special guy
do you have opinions on that or did you
there's a lot going on i think um
look
anyone
as an american or even as a citizen of
the world should just look at this and
just be like there's a complete [ __ ]
show but what did we expect it's almost
like we don't learn any lessons look
back in history what the hell happened
in vietnam america
you can get into a war very easily but i
think we've realized it's very hard to
get out of a war it's very ugly to get
out of a war i think something that we
need to recognize is what's the lesson
here we can be anti-terrorist badass
mother suckers and get in and take care
of business but we cannot
build nations we're not nation builders
we can't go into goddamn middle of the
middle east and think that they're going
to come to around our way of thinking it
didn't happen in iraq it's definitely
never happened in iran it's not
happening afghanistan
let's learn our lesson so the next time
that something happens here
god forbid a 911 happens we don't rush
to judgment 30 days later and declare
war in afghanistan when like you said
before we're fighting at the al qaeda
but al qaeda was our friends in a
different war and now we're fighting the
taliban but now we're making peace with
the taliban because they're fighting
isis k who's like basically the delta
variant of isis
and it's like we can't figure this out
and we never will
we don't understand that way of the
world the government though like it's
from the inside i mean obviously you
have what was his name sheller he goes
online and he starts speaking out and
this guy's getting hit pretty hard
internally
so i think you know obviously it starts
from the inside like when pat you like
you talked about like we can't really do
anything about this this starts inside
we don't know if there's coups involved
in in our own freaking government all
the different branches when you say
inside inside america absolutely you're
telling me that they don't have like
there's drama within our own government
clearly it's our own military clearly
there's different special interests
because how in the hell does this take
place
yeah this is the whole if it's even
within our government let me let me let
me ask you this so you just you just
made a point about hey we can never
solve this and this is problem's always
going to be here it's always been there
it's not all the stuff that you said
okay fine yes but that's not that's not
the challenge right now that we didn't
get here because
nobody agreed on leaving the left and
the right and the middle everybody said
we got to leave there isn't anybody
that's disagreeing on staying except for
the
five to ten percent of the veterans who
are actually there who saw what happened
who have emotional affinity to the
people there that want to see their
lives change and they feel like maybe
we're a generation away except from the
true believers 80 to 90 percent of
america all agrees on let's bring the
troops back fine but here's a question
for you here's a question for you okay
so uh what is the right way you're at a
club okay
there's a shooting you're at a club
there's a shooting you hear a shot goes
out what's the right way to leave the
club
what do you look for when you leave the
the nearest exit the nearest exit and
you leave okay let me ask you a question
do you look for your friends or do you
look i'm just gonna run they're gonna
fight they're gonna find a round of a
way to run as well i'd like to think i
grab my friends who were around me okay
now let me ask you a question here but
if you're if you're with your buddies
and they're all athletes you're probably
like dude you're going to find a way out
dude let's go guys fellas let's get the
hell out of here right in the spur of
the moment are you thinking where's jim
where's where's bob let me flip it like
you know
let me flip it on you let me flip it on
you you're at them all with your two
kids
there's a there's a fire you hear a shot
what's the first thing you're thinking
about grab your kids grab your kids and
then you leave right okay great
you're in your house there's a fire
you got two cats you got a dog and you
got two kids okay
fire breaks out one of the uh propane
blows up and fires everywhere what are
you doing before you leave the house
trying to stop the fire trying to stop
the fire but you're trying to get
everybody out first right is it fair to
say that common sense says what we got
to get the hell out right there is no
common sense that says don't get out so
the problem isn't we got to get out the
problem is how do we get out of here so
you have to prioritize on how you get
out by the way here's a question for you
if you see if you're sitting in a room
you know shit's about to go down what's
the best thing you got to do if you know
the the enemy right there is about to do
something crazy what's the best way for
you to react
let's just say i text you i'm like hey
uh shit's about to go down adam uh phil
gerard in a text
guys uh we have five minutes to get out
of here leaving four
but the way you're going to leave you're
going to be like guys let's not
overreact just like just slowly chill
out just like okay so the way we're
going to do it is you're going to say
i'm going to go to the bathroom and then
gerard's gonna be like you know what i
gotta call let me call my girl yeah and
then gradually i'm like slowly so slowly
you go out you're not going
dude like we that's how we left because
we left like that so the whole point
isn't let's leave we know we need to
leave the division damn right we know we
need to leave the damn mall how we left
so okay so now
uh
leaving afghanistan for dummies okay
let's read that book
let's let's somebody should publish that
book well step number one you got 85
billion dollars of equipment yeah
okay um civilians got to go first so
first of all we need the equipment
civilians got to go first there you go
those translators those interpreters who
helped us out gotta go first then what
goes next
in my opinion the troops go last i agree
with you okay but i don't know why we
put out the troops and we're like oh by
the way but we forgot a hundred thousand
civilians and all our [ __ ] so so thank
you it's ass backwards but think about
how much of this is just pure
common flipping sense because it's it's
reaction versus response
when you react you do what they freaking
did when you respond that means that
you're more calculated period and they
did not have
no more kids like you have a fire drill
yeah like you have certain protocols
systems all that other crap
where was theirs where
where was that list here's the other
part here's the other part if you think
about this okay
there's a part that i
don't agree
with the president saying what we're
about to do next too early here's what i
think i think it's like listen guys i
don't know probably in the next to two
to four years we're gonna try to leave
afghanistan there you go but you leave
in six months but nobody needs to know
that you don't as a
president sit up there yeah here's my
card hey guys we're leaving in the next
week oh [ __ ] they're about to leave in
the next week like look we're going to
try to go in the next two to four years
we'll see what's going to happen okay
and we'll see what's going to take place
but we are working on it we have a plan
we'll see what will happen then you know
you're about to leave in the next 30
days
there's a part of this that
strategically but it it just validates
whoever is that's in the commander of
chief position president position
they're hacked they have to be
strategic
they have to understand the art of war
they have to understand power
and then the subtle maneuvering you
don't just go and say hey
i don't know i'm just know me it's a
bill you said you said it a while ago on
a podcast i believe last time i was here
uh
that the commander-in-chief needs to
have some experience serving in the
military because of what you just said
i mean if they if he had some level of
experience of expertise
he would
actually have to know
the art of war all these things that you
described or or you know how we do it
let's just say you don't okay let's
because we're going to go in an era
where a guy's going to be a president
like a trump biden bush let's just say
these guys here's how it works
you're the final vote
but you got a board of six seven you're
one of the votes but you're the
executive chairman when it comes if
you've never served in the military
you're gonna put generals there uh
marines air force army everybody that's
your national security you put your
national security council and right
there the vote is
four
if four in that room say boom go but
it's not one biden doesn't get a chance
to vote neither trump neither any of
these guys yeah you sit there and say
boom let's get out a few things that
that really come to mind from this thing
is the way bonds handled it really makes
me feel like he's not running the show
he's a puppet i'm not supposed to answer
questions i'm not supposed to who you're
the president who's telling you what to
do if anything you should be standing up
with your chest out and saying like
but but it's it's very obvious and i'm
not and that's not like i'm not trying
to knock biden on this now i'm like
legitimately concerned who's calling the
shots here man that's number one
absolutely number two all right is i
think it's beyond obvious now like you
said it before what are we learning from
this why why we can't nation build adam
i don't think they ever intended to i
think that they were there to
to suck millions and millions of dollars
and keep these incredibly high paying
jobs why do they not care about eight
billion dollars worth of ordinance being
left behind because it wasn't their
money
they don't care it didn't come out of
their pocket that stuff was already
bought and paid for and in fact the
defense contractors are like let them
have it we got to buy new stuff
absolutely they don't want to win these
wars they just want to keep them going
for as long as possible this thing made
them i don't disagree so much money and
the patriot act right we have the
patriot act we have tsa now they said
they're trying to spin it they're trying
to spin this that we don't need to be
there anymore because we we we hit the
objective it was osama bin laden was the
objective okay well then the patriot act
was there because of bin laden and al
qaeda and now you're telling us the
taliban have learned their lesson so why
do we still have to go through tsa why
are we still doing all that bs is that
just again and now what does that mean
to me with everything we're doing today
that was the quote-unquote new normal
yeah and that was supposed to go away
but now the patriot act is never going
away right we live in a surveillance
state just like taxes it's never going
away so learn from learn what do you
you're to your point adam what can we
learn from this be very careful which
freedoms you give away in in in terms of
well i just want to feel safe because
we're learning right now when the crisis
is over
you're not getting them back it's not
happening let me add to your point you
you've talked and talked use this term
the military industrial complex yep it's
a real thing
this is disgusting to see what's going
on here so something that pat always
says here that we learned anyone who
starts with valuetainment says
treat the company's money like it's your
own do you not say that pat
treat the company's money so if you're
going to go out and get a hotel you're
going to get a car rental you're going
to get equipment you're going to get
whatever you're going to treat it like
it's your own and you're not going to
waste some spending save that money
and it's just disgusting to see
how much waste and fraud is going on
there with within government spending
yeah it's disgusting so let's circle
back to the original question what were
they supposed to do with this equipment
if they weren't they're not how are they
getting tanks back how are they getting
bombers back
they see i've never been in the military
but it seems obvious rather than letting
them have it don't you just blow that
[ __ ] up why wouldn't you
explain to me why you wouldn't just
and you know that crazy an enemy
to go back in and create another 10
years exactly
what you said is what trump said
but i don't know if you're what trump
said he said here's a plan
first you get the civilians out yes then
you get the interpreters out let's just
say the allies then
you get some of the equipment out then
you blow every unit up you blow it up
because if there's any anything you blow
every base up that we have then we get
the troops that come back up yeah that
was his formula on how to do it so you
were just aligned with trump i'm not i'm
not even making this a a president i'm
aligned with trump i'm allowed to buy
and thing like you said
but trump never served but
here's my point well no wait a minute
you're aligned with common sense sure
great awesome that's a first for me
right bingo no it's not here we got a
first for you if if if americans
actually looked at this [ __ ] they're
not from the standpoint of who is
president or rather from common sense we
many people would be on the same side i
agree but my point is this
forget about trump forget about biden
forget about bush forget obama because
they're all guilty and they're all we're
involved in this war i mean starting
from bush obama has been
the generals
you're the ones calling the shots yeah
you're the ones in there saying look
i've been in war i've been in
afghanistan for 20 years here's what we
need to do
who's the loudmouth general out there
talking right now it's so easy to blame
biden or so easy to blame trump and
trump did the deal and biden just went
through with the so easy why aren't the
generals it's hard it's hard for them
because they all they went all in on the
establishment to get rid of trump so
it's hard it's very hard for a guy like
mattis who i'm a big fan of it's very
hard for him right now to be like i i i
backed the wrong horse uh you know it's
very very difficult but the point is
this like who cares that you're talking
about america i agree with you yeah but
that's the residential but this is also
when you say that who cares stuff again
like this is uh you know
because because it's in this moment
you've been so vilified in this in this
divisive political environment like this
is what i'm saying when i talk about i
don't want taxes taxes are theft and if
people are like i don't mind paying my
fair share if it means that a kid can
read and education gets better and
there's no child
how they walk when they're talking yeah
but they're with their with their warby
parker's
like people i'm about to say he's the
easier way no it's not no it's not this
is what your tax money goes to your tax
money doesn't your tax money doesn't go
to
kids getting books in schools your tax
money goes to this
so until these people tell you and show
you that they can use the hours of your
life we've discussed this taxes aren't
just money money represents the hours of
your life that is eight billion hours of
american lives left behind for the enemy
to play around with and hang people from
apache freaking helicopters that's
subsidized by you and me guys that right
there high five guys we didn't we
sponsored that and we're not going to
talk about this like my question is how
long are we going to continually talk
about this to drive that point home to
the general public because there's a lot
of people in this world that don't pay
attention to politics in this way they
don't pay attention to military in this
way this type of news needs to be
continuously over and over and there
that
there's a lesson to be learned in this
and we're all discussing it right here
but until that becomes like the norm
we're we're going to do this [ __ ] again
the other lesson we learned i know we're
going to talk about we avoid i know
we're going to talk about this but the
other lesson we learned is every time
they tell you that you can't take on the
government like all these second
amendment guys we got f-16s yeah yeah
right they got everything i'm laughing
in farsi i laugh in north vietnam yeah
you're telling me that i'll give up my
guns because why because
eric swalwell you don't have nukes yeah
what did the taliban have
don't ever ever
get your second amendment you know they
said the taliban officially moved up 161
spots in the strongest military in the
world
a hundred from our stuff from our stuff
161 spots spots
in the strongest military in the world
so that means they're like in the top 50
right now can i think about the taliban
the taliban's military after what they
just took
is in the top 50 militaries in the world
right now what is their ties and i'm
just going off here like what are their
ties with the communist pioneer china
do they have any ties with them well
they have ties with pakistan and then
pakistan has ties i'm just talking i'm
just thinking in regards to like
technology and stuff like that it's a
good thought because this is this is all
a proxy because if yeah because i'm
thinking well like okay like who's
responsible for this who's responsible
for everybody's got to be responsible
for something who's last night you and i
had a conversation together right we had
a little bit of a hiccup and we're
talking to each other and like yeah you
know what my how my hair got too high by
the way yeah it's a funny story behind
that i like the hair so we're talking
and we say hey
but the point is who who who gets the
responsibility on this adam who gets the
responsibility on this
are you looking for a figurehead or well
you listen i mean
you know
everything rises and falls on leadership
who's responsible for this look i i if
you want to go the easy clear answer
biden and he's he even went out and said
look this is on me
he said this um what should be the
repercussions
well the voters will determine that well
but we can't wait that long but what i'm
asking you is
he's not getting impeached it's not like
none of that okay it's not happening so
let me ask you a question let's just say
we go there because you know republicans
are like let's impeach the guy okay fine
but let's just what you're saying yeah
but the liberals wanted to impeach trump
twice and they celebrate the first time
in history a president got impeached
twice on their resume right okay
let's and then they're saying let's
resign them and then they're saying
court martial right
how should he be held accountable to
this i'm actually curious right like
nixon resigned over what
nixon watergate watergate which was what
today watergate is like a step number
three it's like watergate is nothing
today done by both sides watergate is
very obama literally did it and got
nothing happened no question about it so
did hillary it's a very simple model but
how should he be held accountable not
just voting how should he build
accountable today because in a corporate
world in a corporate world if i run a
corporation and i accidentally cost the
corporation 85 billion dollars you know
what happens to a guy like me i mean
like the board is going to sit down and
say steve jobs we kind of love you but
dude you are fired and we're going to
bring in a scully and we're going to
bring you back seven years later if you
earned the right but right what should
happen to this guy today why should why
should free enterprise
have more pressure of their job being
fired in the moment but government
employees they can just sit there and
say dude no one's gonna fire me what
should happen today well that's the
problem that is the very essence of the
issue with authoritarian regimes
communism socialism however you want to
call it
there is no accountability in government
we talked about it before it's not your
money it's somebody else's money and it
and and if you blow it you know on a
micro scale we talked about bill de
blasio's wife bill de blasio's wife made
a billion dollars a billion dollars of
taxpayer money disappeared there wasn't
an investigation there wasn't criminal
charges she got promoted she is now
handling the dissemination of the funds
so what should be done what do you do
well
by the way there's two people that look
very good right now
there's two people that look very good
right now one of them you know
the other one is jimmy carter okay how
how does jimmy carter look good right
now yes who did better him or uh biden
biden is making carter look good
biden is making carter carter sitting
there saying at least i'll be able to
say i'm not the worst
of all george bush and dick cheney are
skating by on this and i they look
biden's bad but bush and cheney need to
need to have the the spotlight shine on
him cheney especially because he's back
this time around in this camp
you know donald rumsfeld your boy i hate
him hey horrible horrible horrible human
being an embarrassment to me rumsfeld no
no vice was a great oh i didn't see it
yeah you did not see violence i didn't
see it you're kidding me nah
why why
like i mean i'm uh hollywood doesn't
like a republican i think to answer your
question
genuinely i think it's too early please
listen folks everybody knows everything
adam's going to give us i think it's a
little too early to just start dishing
out blame yes this is going not
according to plan correct okay cool i
don't think anybody likes to see what's
going on here but let's see what the
long-term ramifications of this the
bottom line is this
americans overwhelmingly did not want to
be in afghanistan let's not just like
gloss over that for years and years
already addressed that okay but for
years and years we paid zero attention
to this for years and years our military
our government was lying basically
saying everything's fine
don't worry about afghanistan we got it
all under control turns out they were
lying the entire time turns out we could
not control 75 000 taliban fighters
turns out 75 000 people fighting for
their homeland fighting for infidels
is a lot more powerful than any amount
of army that's getting paid to play well
you don't have to win you just have to
stalemate
it's how we've got the british to get
this country but stalemate for how long
20 years 50 years 100 years
i think the bottom line is i think we
have way too many internal issues in
america to be worried about afghanistan
it sucks what's going on short term
right now but with everything that's
going on in america
you name the list of issues debt
obviously our tax system health care
homelessness the list goes on and on and
on
yeah now we're now we're worried about
the afghani people with all due respect
we've got enough countries no no but
this has got nothing to do with afghani
people
what what does this have to do with
afghanistan what what
what part of this issue is afghani
people
what part of yeah what part of this is
afghani people
i mean you're saying yeah you're saying
let's forgive we have so many issues
here let's forget about that
you know the people in afghanistan but
let's address our issues nobody
disagrees but is this an afghani people
issue
no this is an american government
spending and focus issue this is this is
this is a this is a
this is a strategic issue okay if you
hire a c-suite executive
you hire a c-suite executive because
you're expecting this person to be
competent in what areas
and they're whatever they're
specifically whatever they specialize in
right okay if i'm a cmo my job is to do
a great job and what just like you're a
general in the army i expect to be
competent at leading an army exactly
what level of competency did you see in
this move that took place two weeks ago
that's the question that we all have is
who's the one
what i'm saying to you is you're saying
we already have so many problems
this could have been prevented if the
level of competency was done in a
different way this is not a issue that
we disagree in this is an issue of
competency this is an issue of common
sense this is an issue of basic strategy
for a person that in
113 billion people have been born from
day one till today you see that
statistic of how many people have lived
there's only been 46 positions for u.s
presidents he's one of them don't you
think there needs to be a little bit
more competency when it comes down to
issues like this that's the only thing
i'm questioning we talked last night
crazy i asked gerard last night if
you're comfortable answering this you
can say it on camera i asked gerard
would you rather have hillary clinton as
a president or joe biden what'd you say
hillary clinton how long did it take for
his answer
what did you say
hillary okay now here's a question would
you rather have trump as president today
or biden
on this particular issue or every issue
in america just no just just take just
take overall competency
decision-making process would you rather
have biden or would you have trump
on this particular issue obviously biden
is failing there's other things that i
think is doing better than trump such i
don't think it's a binary option but but
i think it is though because i think
it's competency like i think i honestly
think as much as
there is nowhere that i'm gonna one day
have a hillary clinton autograph in my
office
i don't seek for that
but i honestly maybe a bill maybe a bill
clinton autograph but i don't mind a
bill but i will you literally have but
but i will tell you something i i i i've
never uh i know you you should i don't i
don't this is not guys this has got
nothing this has got to do to me
who's a bigger badass hillary or biden
not biden biden wasn't elected to be a
badass that's not that's the problem
that's the problem
this is a competency issue and a
leadership issue folks if you're
watching this right now if you're
watching this right now you have two
choices
you have trump i'm sorry you have biden
or hillary who do you pick and by the
way this is like a interesting crowd
right who do you pick you have a bite or
a trump issue who do you pick this is a
leadership issue
this is not about who won or who didn't
win the world hated trump because trump
was pushing everyone's buttons he was
the obnoxious guy that's going out there
and calling you out hey you got a big
belly hell your nose is big hey you got
a big pimple on your forehead that's
trump
is that fair to say that's his style
he's going to go and call everybody and
just get under everyone's skin well he
also turned the free money spigot off
which is why they really got real and
then he put all the sanctions on
everybody he decided like he said you
know what i'm gonna go from uh a person
everybody wants to be like me kid
grosser wants to be like donald trump
rappers want to be like donald trump i'm
gonna go to be the most hated person in
the world by pushing everyone's buttons
he just woke up one day saying i'm gonna
push your butt in china mexico canada
everybody and he had the formula down
but when it comes down to situations
like this because your top position
presidency
out of everything you and i need to do
in the job okay maybe let me ask this
back and we'll change topic because
we've got other things to get into
here's a question for you
tell me the number one quality of a
great comedian not top five the number
one you guys are in that world i have no
idea i think it's charisma
is it timing is it charisma you can
learn timing i think it's charisma you
can't fake it i don't know what do you
say timing and charisma you put timing
first or charisma give me one of them i
just want you reading the room i said
charisma okay charisma what do you say
charisma for sure okay fine fair but
what's simple without what's the number
one quality of a person that could win
mr olympia that could win mr olympia not
be competing for mr olympia but win
mushroom i think i know the answer but
i'm curious what you say you definitely
have to own the crowd okay i mean
obviously if you have the physique i
mean that's that you have to have the
physique okay so that's number one yes
you have to have genetics you have to
have the genetics is that fair oh
absolutely if you don't have it it
doesn't matter like chad nichols said i
can take everything i'm never going to
win mr correct you've got to have a gift
uh somebody said like a seven times a
stroll
okay let's continue what is number one
number one not top five what is the
number one quality for you to uh have a
girl go from being a girlfriend to a
wife
number one not top five
maybe a bad question for you right now
i think uh every every woman says they
want to have uh a good communicator
someone who listens okay so someone
wants to ability stability would that be
security stability fair that's right
he's working on stability he's getting
stable he's moved into his new spot i'm
proud of you what's the number one rule
of becoming a millionaire
number save that goddamn money okay so
let's just say you save the money right
what is the number one
duty
of being a president not top five not
top ten number one protect your people
secure your borders boom you got it so
what i'm trying to tell you
is everything that happens this year
nothing is above securing your people
that's number one and he's not doing it
and trump did
okay
there's presidents that did he did not
do that and that's what you get held
accountable for that's accountability
that is only thing i'm asking for
because you have to be competent
last night i hear [ __ ] in the backyard
who has to get up and grab the gun and
go walk around damn right i have to do
it
i'm the guy that's the security of the
house i don't say
well let me send my 79 year old dad to
go see it jimbo yeah let me go see
what's going on okay there's a big-ass
possum on steroids sitting outside like
massive benching three plates
i'm like freaking this guy
so he's in the backyard
but the point is the point is competency
security a husband a man provides
security competency for the family a
president has to give us confidence that
if somebody comes and invades us or does
something to us that person is going to
put the freaking
a level of fear in the other person to
say dude i'm pulling out i'm kicking
back listen i gotta give you a [ __ ]
sounds like you agree with joe benano's
book a little bit we need a head of a
family is that the idea
you're going back to mafia you're
watching way too much mafia
[Music]
made the same argument we just need one
guy he takes care of everybody it's like
a father maybe you'd say a boss i don't
think it's just one guy i just think
like to me when you think about somebody
where you're gonna say okay like right
now you look at candidates as an
ex-president you gotta think about
somebody that's gonna be protecting the
nation you have to think about somebody
that's gonna protect them i think and
make other people think twice when they
want to screw with america i mean that's
that's i think more than anything else
guys we as citizens have to look at this
and say this central planning can never
work because this is what's always going
to happen this idea that some government
some altruistic government is gonna come
and they're gonna take care of
everything they can't figure anything
out all it takes is one batch of peter
principle and ruins the entire empire
man get rid of imperialism because it's
impossible and it's not profitable
except for very few people at the top
capitalism is the way not imperialism
and also guys the centralized stuff and
now they're going to pivot the climate
change they're pivoting on the climate
crisis they're making
what happened in canada oh it's all over
it's australia new zealand canada where
uh trudeau came out and said we're gonna
we're going to apply the lessons learned
from this war on kovid in the war
against the climate crisis and all of
our environmental crisis and inequity
and and so uh social justice and was
like wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa the
lessons learned like in new york right
now today you know i love talking about
my my favorite home soviet block new
york city right the the the great uh
hugo new york
it's
it you have
to show your papers
you have to show your papers you have to
show yourselves your paper
where's your paper so you cannot get
into the bodega today yeah it's it's you
can't eat groceries without showing now
here's what's asinine about this if you
have a covet vaccine you can still be
positive coven positive and go eat at a
restaurant but it's okay you you've got
your ouchy so no big deal but if you if
you test negative all right like cole
beasley if you test negative and you've
been exposed to somebody
all right who did a test but they but
they complied it's okay they they can
feed their children did you see the
article i sent yesterday
um i don't even know if we want to get
into yeah phd's
you know what we should care more about
the channel than anyone
that anyone hears opinions you know what
[ __ ] it let's get the channel taken down
who needs the channel at this point
[ __ ] hey oh you're crazy
but let me ask you guys
but let me ask you this it was a great
article if anybody wants to get this
article send me a tweet
patrick david maybe later on today i'll
share the article with you it was a very
interesting article sent to us by one of
our good friends here anyways so listen
weird weird week or no weird week or no
yeah yeah weird month
we're sitting we're sitting in the in
the uh room and you guys talk about what
happened to miami
okay
and what happened to miami and i we go
on and we watch the video disturbing
video i'm not even gonna show it but
it's disturbing video where yeah yeah
young walking through it yeah young
gentleman uh apparently was high on
mushrooms uh walks up uh a a very young
couple 21 years old and 22 years old
one-year-old child sitting in miami
outdoors like we all do just enjoying a
meal over on uh ocean ocean drive and a
dude walks up with a gun sticks it in
the guy's face he goes whoa i got my
baby in my hand hands the baby to his
he's 21 years old this kid hands the
baby to his wife and the guy goes okay
now now you don't and boom
caps
right there middle of the restaurant
daylight broad daylight non-provoked
just apparently
anybody who's ever taken mushrooms no
mushrooms don't do that to you so i
don't know maybe bath salts or something
he starts dancing like fortnight like
dancing over the body like fortnight and
then uh just walks away apparently shot
at somebody else and missed them and
then three cops man who
god bless these guys the balls of these
dudes they just they they
charged them attacked them took them
down and he admitted the whole thing
while he was being taken down it was i'd
love to see what was in his actual it
wasn't
can you imagine just going with your
your your young wife i mean he's 21
years old it's probably the first
vacation he's ever freaking been on
they're at miami beach just chilling
loving life look at the sun and the fun
and the guy comes up and just boom let
me let me ask you a question i mean this
this this transitions us into the
conversation we had yesterday right
uh and the conversation is about god
right now if you look at god the debate
for god is what let's look at the
debates for god there's how many
different camps with god oh so many
there is the camp of people who believe
there is a god and within that camp
there's how many religions a ton too
many pick and choose but there's a ton
right
you know
judaism
christianity lds jehovah
muslim
you know if you want to put scientology
in that camp christian catholicism
buddhism buddhism taoism
sikhs there's a lot right but they
believe there is a creator there's a god
the other camp is what well agnostic
they believe there is a god they just
don't know
not convinced not convinced and then you
have the atheists that flata believes
what
there's not a god yeah the community for
atheists believe it or not is very small
it's only like four million people it's
not a big number worldwide it's not a
big number if you look at the can you
kind of pull up what percentage of the
world uh
total uh atheist population worldwide i
think i think it's a
it's not a big number it's a small
number anyway so we got three different
camps okay i thought it would be larger
than that yeah me too
us's three million worldwide is what 450
to 500 million
uh there are 450 atheists and agnostic
wait a minute because that's not that's
not the same thing so atheists and
agnostic i don't put them in the same
camp agnostic is a completely different
uh understanding than atheists exhausted
just to be clear i think atheism is you
basically say there is no god agnostic
is you're not sure if there is or there
isn't you just don't know yeah that's
you don't know which is fine so that's
not like a no matter what there's not a
god okay
so it's okay we'll figure it out later
okay
so now today with everything that's
going on okay
uh do we have more people believing in
god today or fewer people believing in
god today
i would guess fewer
percentage-wise i don't know because not
that population percentage i think well
it depends when you say god like when
people start using the term like
celestial creator or a universal energy
i feel like they're still believing in
god they're believing in something like
when you talked about people praying you
know how how praying centers you uh and
that people should pray more i'm like
man i feel like people talk about prayer
now more than when i was a kid they just
rebranded it as uh
as manifesting manifest
right manifesting the seeker yeah and
it's like that because there's someone's
praying that's praying they're scared is
that not praying yeah they use the word
meditation yeah i meditate it's what i
do and rather than saying prayer they
use meditation it's a more politically
correct way or affirmations as well
meditation is slightly different than
affirmation affirmation is restating the
same thing over and over and over again
until you believe it meditation is more
you're sitting there you're praying
you're thinking about a topic what do
you do pat no i listen i gotta tell you
i mean for me
uh prayer is is magical you know tom's
in a hospital tom's in the hospital with
pneumonia and cobit right thomas tom
zenner yeah
tom ellsworth he's in the hospital with
pneumonia he was in icu for the last
couple of days you have so biz dog the
best dog so what yes he's uh he's there
now man
today's his best day okay today's best
day okay
i hope you're listening we're thinking
of you man we miss you yeah everybody
misses me
is he gonna is there any chance he's
gonna be here for the vault or we don't
know we're gonna see what's gonna happen
the only thing we're thinking about is
his health right
so prayer okay prayer to me but i think
about
like we we went to the question and said
okay what country would you rather
raise your kids in would you rather live
in a country where the top believes in
certain values and principle and there
being a god or the top believes in there
is no god they're atheists they're
agnostic like yeah you know whatever we
don't need to follow a certain guy
judeo-christian values you prefer that
values and principles yeah what we grew
up with
but let's take that out
let's take that out and let's say we
don't have that what does that world
look like
let's take that let's take it out and
say listen i think it's like you know i
used to go to school we used to pray you
don't do that anymore you used to go to
school you used to stand up to you know
the flag you don't do that and it's
offensive we used to go and do certain
rituals right i remember one time i met
the owner of public storage's house in
l.a in malibu beautiful home and dennis
prager got up and he says what makes a
great country is great and what makes
religions great is rituals and he's a
jew and you know jews have a lot of
symbolism a lot of symbolism and rituals
right we used to pray we don't do that
anymore so imagine like you're standing
up and praying to a flag or standing up
and saluting to a flag or looking up to
a flag what does that do to a
six-year-old what does it do to an
eight-year-old what does it do to a 10
year old what does it do when you pray
do you really believe in prayer at that
time do you sit there and say oh my gosh
prayer works or do you sit there and say
what if this works i don't know if this
works what does a kid think about but at
least you're thinking right well maybe
someone's got my back maybe someone's
watching me is it good to think a
creator is watching us have we gotten
away from that why don't we want a
creator to watch us is it because we
don't like accountability is it because
we want to be kind of a
rebels and not have anybody hold this
account what is it like what or is it
because we had a bad experience with a
pastor with a preacher with a priest
something happened like dude i don't
believe in any churches that's what
happened with me i wasn't i was an
atheist for 25 years
but the more and more you see the world
being a little bit out of whack
the more and more you question you know
what i don't know
maybe we need a little bit more
faith today not faith maybe we need a
little bit more prayer today maybe we
need somebody to just get up and say you
know what america times are a little bit
weird i think we got to pray today we
have somebody that just sits there like
you know like flat out a person gets up
there and prays for the entire country
today what if that happened how would
the world react how would america react
maybe the man upstairs if there is a man
upstairs is not happy
maybe imagine if a father did so much
for his kid and his kids are so spoiled
how would that father react
how would the father react with the
father sit there yesterday i was doing a
mentoring call on the elite webinar one
of the guys a guy kid named george liked
them and i said so tell me george says
well let me tell you you know i think of
myself as one of these bill gates type
of guys i'm very cold nothing offends me
i don't get upset like he's talking in a
big game he's 23 years old i said so
really what kind of business do you run
he said i don't run a business i work
for my father my father you know he
doesn't know what he's doing i said your
dad doesn't know what he's doing no he
really doesn't know what he's done so
what is your dad he has a bunch of
hotels in greece and he's got a big
portfolio of real estate of 100 some
million dollars but i do it at all for
him i said really you managed to yeah
and we got all these seven other ceos
that are watching us that do 20 100
million a year in business i said so
tell me
who needs more do you need your dad or
does he need you more oh no question my
dad can't survive without me i'm like oh
really he said yeah so what are you
gonna do he said well next year i'm
gonna go away from my dad and do it on
my own i said fantastic what's your game
plan he's gonna give me a few million
dollars to get started
i'm like everybody starts cracking i'm
like did you just hear yourself so my
dad did for me it was fine yeah so
so maybe if there is a creator just
maybe this creator if there is and he
plays the role of a father maybe he's a
little disappointed with all the stuff
that we have 100
maybe i don't know gerard what are your
thoughts
it's a long conversation um
i gotta tell you man i am a man of faith
i believe in a creator i believe in a
universe i have a weird belief that we
are all uh connected of the same energy
i think science has kind of proven that
matter cannot be created or destroyed
we're all stardust we're all
interconnected and what i said yesterday
is that i believe in in a collective
consciousness i believe there's this
thing called noetic science that kind of
studies this but there's this there's a
reason why home field advantage works
their collective consciousness is a real
thing there's a reason why prayer groups
seem to actually have effect right
so i think our collective consciousness
is off right now i think there's
something there there is sand in the
microchip i personally don't have much
like or use for religion i think faith
is of god religion is of man and i think
religion has been a tool used
for authorities
and not unlike government in this regard
i feel like it is a thing for uh people
that are addicted to power to use to try
to take power and control over their
fellow man let me jump in on that if you
don't mind yeah because this came up
on my app this morning
and i love what you just said it says
from ephesians 6 12
it says for our wrestling and not
against flesh and blood but against the
principalities against the powers
against the world rulers of this
darkness against the spiritual host of
wickedness in the heavenly places
so you know what that basically means is
that we're going through a lot of
craziness right now in this world
and that
we need to be guarded
extremely guarded we and therefore we
need to come together no matter if you
believe in god or whatever we need to
come together and pat you brought up a
great
story about your son
you know praying you know showing prayer
and stuff like that at the end of the
day whether you believe in prayer or not
it's just positivity
we need to come together in some way and
understand that
something's wrong and in order to get
right we got to get right with ourselves
and we need to really have better
conversations
when you say you know i hear people say
love thy neighbor this that you're just
saying it you're not doing it
we're living in a world of just words
words words no actions no real honesty
hypocrisy is at an all-time high with
our leaders and all that stuff we have
no guts to even call out and then when
we do call out these so-called rulers
leaders we get canceled we get thrown to
the side and then when they come the
pendulum shifts
like we were talking about earlier like
you know you have the left doing all
this blah blah blah and then now this
whole biden thing now people from the
right are like point c cc it's like but
that doesn't work either if we could
just say you know what man
oh yeah you messed up
but
i'm going to show you some grace
because there's a bigger goal here and
the goal is this
peace and we're on righteousness stuff
like that
yeah i don't know i think uh um you know
obviously where you are and where you
are you know with ephesians you just
read right there what is prayer think
about what prayer is prayer is what you
don't pray and say god i would love it
if you gave me a lamborghini tomorrow
and i would love if we get a ferrari and
if i get a hundred thousand dollar check
i will be more christian next week and
if you give me that ferragamo shoes with
the nice stefano richie suit
i'm going to go to church you're coming
for joel osteen hardy so yeah i'm going
after joel osteen
but you know what prayer is prayer is
prayer forces you to think about other
people
prayer is you know what i'm praying for
gerard you know he's going through a
certain phase right now probably jared
told me something about his mom his dad
his brother or sister i'm gonna pray for
him man he looked like he was going
through some time right now i'm gonna
pray for adam you know hey you know he's
going through this i'm gonna pray for
tom
the part about prayer is makes you think
about others
it meditation is more you
most of the time prayer is out
you're praying for someone else so what
would happen if we're coming from that
mindset you're thinking about other
people look for me
all i know is you give me a great
organization you give me a great family
that keeps winning you're gonna find
strong values and principles there and
the moment values and principles goes
away
havoc's about to take place okay now the
the the part about the the faith that we
didn't get into yesterday is
how many people you know that use
bible as a weapon how many people do you
know that use
the the scripture as weapons i think
history is is chock full of i don't
disagree yeah yeah muslims may say a lot
of people use the quran as a weapon 75
of them say this is a religion of what
peace peace right hey you know there's
extremists but that's not us
you know guns let's talk about guns has
gone a good invention to the world i
think they think it's one of the
greatest inventions ever who did it help
the most men or women
women by far
what give me the split ten to one twenty
to one five to one i mean i mean we
talked about this you know
in podcast past but i mean like
literally this is the first time in the
history of our species yeah that not
being big strong and violent is the
the the marker of success and that the
the gun has equaled the playing field
for smaller people more intelligent
people even if people are able to
no longer just just bully their way into
success you can't get you know in a ship
with 16 other norsemen and go you know
across uh the english channel and take
over an entire channel yeah so i mean
again we talked about with lebron james
and i call him the repentant rich i'm
like never in the history of man could
somebody that was born in that status of
life in akron ohio become a billionaire
he would have had to kill or been
responsible for organizing an army that
killed
millions of people hundreds of thousands
of people in order to go from poverty to
a literal prince a king like that so you
know the fact that he's a billionaire by
playing ball and hole and the fact that
he can go and be on tv every day where
everybody knows where he is and they
know that he has all this money and
everything like that and he doesn't have
to worry about his family being at home
or his stuff being at home he doesn't go
to sleep every night wondering if oh my
god there's going to be marauders coming
to take everything that i've i've earned
in the middle of the night he has
indirectly guns to thank for that yeah
so let me let me jump in for a sec so
there's two
we started this conversation with
basically saying look we're a little off
track here right now you know we kind of
got to get
our central nervous system of our
consciousness together
but at the same time like what you're
saying i think this is the best that
humans have ever lived ever ever it's
quantified so exactly so you know like
charles dickens it was the best of times
it's the worst of times it's so easy to
point out all the bad stuff all this guy
on mushrooms like it's crazy uh isis al
qaeda whatever whatever how many people
have been lifted out of poverty how many
people
over the last 50 years how many people
have clean drinking water now how many
people how many babies aren't dying
because polio isn't killing them the
second they're born it's so easy to just
jump on and pile on the bad the negative
things are bad which some in some cases
they are
but a lot of things are good man well a
lot of things these things are good i
think the the term is gratitude
and i think uh a lot of us have to live
in that moment a little bit more right
like instead of just complaining and
whining and wretching and moaning we
have to be in more gratitude and like
you said i mean
we are living in some
very strange times but at the same time
i mean look we're able to have this
podcast connect with people you know
we'll be changing you know hopefully
someone's perspective life whatever in
just us having this uh conversation yeah
you know but uh you know i feel very
fortunate in a lot of things i get to do
and that's because of you know evolution
so pat let me ask you this so you
brought up guns there so are you saying
that religion to you is analogous to a
gun absolutely a lot of people here are
talking uh insane stuff like let me read
some what couple people said
uh uh uh
wars wars wars bible is a marco d pascal
bible is mostly fake and paul braz is
100 right uh you got another guy that's
talking about most paul baraz just gave
10 bucks and he said most people in
fairy tales
most most believe in fairy tales god and
religion sure seek
uh like it works lol
uh you know people talking trash about
god right and talking trash about bible
there's an interesting thing about the
bible i will say and i i love this stuff
by the way like i i spend my weekends
reading up about this stuff i told you
about my affinity for the historical
jesus whether i believe he's the son of
god or not the he's the greatest
activist of all time i am fascinated
with the life of of of yeshua i'm
fascinated by it and really the bible
and this is going to piss some people
off but just try to have an open mind
the bible really all right that we know
today
is a treaty
between
judaism monotheism and the roman empire
catholicism is a great
uh it's it's an understanding between
the growing sex of judaism jesus never
wanted christianity he was a jew through
and through rabbi and there was roman
catholicism right roman catholicism was
the um what's the word i'm looking for
here the the uh
the compromise it was the compromise
between the dying old roman ways and the
new
roman as rome became eastern not western
so there's there's geopolitical like
it's fascinating politics behind this
stuff
if you can it and i'm not saying that
jesus isn't the son of god i'm not
saying that that it's not the word of
god that's not what i'm saying but if
you believe that religion is of man all
right and you know if you if you can
research the council of nicaea
understanding what this was from a
political standpoint is the most
fascinating times in human history we're
still talking about two thousand years
later it's the the council of nicaea
shaped the world for the next you know
twelve hundred thirteen hundred years
it's it's a fascinating time man so
anyway i'm sorry but you asked you asked
a question though you asked the question
saying the gun comparison to bible right
okay yeah so here's here's how i see
this
uh anything can be used as a weapon
anything can be used as a weapon right
they they they say the moment you learn
how to persuade never go to the tipping
point of manipulate just to avoid you
being wrong at times
when you learn how to persuade
you're one
one move away from being a manipulator
just because you don't want because now
you know how to win arguments okay so if
the
mission becomes about winning you will
tip into manipulating rather than
persuading i don't know if that makes
sense yeah it's kind of like what
lawyers are trying to do
so once you learn how to persuade you're
like listen this guy knows how to
persuade you know how to persuade you
know how to present i know how to
persuade but there's like you know what
in this argument he's beating me screw
it i'm going to manipulate because i
don't want to be yeah and by the way
that's a problem and that's a problem
everybody with power that knows how to
persuade has to deal with everybody
happens in marriage parenting right
everything does okay let's set that part
aside computer that's a weapon
the bible can be used as a weapon this
is a weapon this right here is one of
the most powerful weapons in the world
today right
so there's there's a couple arguments me
i went through the phase of trying to
break everything down with the bible to
prove to everybody that the bible is
wrong that was my outcome you think the
bible is right yes you mean to tell me
that back in the days a woman's gonna
have a baby without and yeah we have to
believe it you want me to believe it
this was this the 23 year old kid that
would go to every pastor that he could
find and i would try to prove him wrong
that was this guy we're 20 to 23 years
old this is all i did for two and a half
years right you mean to tell me i have
to believe that let me get this straight
what makes you think maybe she uh hooked
up with a guy that nobody knew about and
then boom next thing you know she's got
a baby to save her she has to say well
this is a god all this stuff right okay
then people say
well let's just say she made that up
okay let's just say she made that up
what are the freaking chances
that she makes up the story
and the kid ends up becoming the biggest
influencer in the world
let's say so for me the skeptic is like
well
well there's chances what are the
chances 113 freaking billion okay math
genius break that down for me then i
back up i'm like [ __ ] that was it
let me take a different angle well back
in the days people were so naive and a
person could come up with a great
communicator they can manipulate
everybody so you can use that as a
weapon to manipulate others okay great
it's still happening today but fine
let's just say the ivt level is lower
today people were more knife back in the
days because they wanted to be
controlled
every time i went to it finally it got
to the following point here's what the
point is
are there some things you will never
know about your dad and your mom that
they will never tell you
are there stuff you're never going to
know about your parents like you know a
couple of the arguments or that part of
this one are there things that you will
never find out yes or no
if you spend the rest of your life
trying to figure out 100 accuracy of
who's right mom or dad are you ever
going to find that out yes or no you're
never going to find it out right okay
you can spend the rest of your life
trying to find out every single thing
about christianity jesus god everything
are you going to find that a hundred
percent truth of all of it 100 truth not
not 98
100 truth
so then that leaves us with what okay so
you got emotional you got logical let's
look at both sides okay
for me
on the logical side
um
do i want my kids to learn certain
values and principles to follow do i
feel more comfortable a country is being
built on a certain set of values and
principles yes would i rather have my
kids go to church and not go to church
yes would i rather have my kids pray
than not to pray yes would i rather have
my kids go to an atheist school or
jewish school and i'm a christian myself
i would try to have would i rather have
my kids be held accountable to a certain
level so this whole thing about you're
right you're delusional you're this
you're that look you're talking to a guy
that spent the entire time trying to
mathematically prove everybody wrong in
the concept of bible oh noah you mean to
tell me this guy built a ship and two
animals on each side and came and all of
you you mean come on bro that's a
freaking fictional story you believe
that i don't know
i don't know you mean to tell me that
such as i don't know what i'm trying to
tell you is i don't know what i am
telling you is if a person reads
proverbs they become a better human
being i don't know why
go read proverbs and see what happens to
you i don't know why i don't care what
you are just go start with proverbs read
to see what happens afterwards i think
we need a little bit this is coming from
a guy that's a sinner this is coming
from a guy that's flawed this is coming
from a guy that's done a lot of stupid
[ __ ] in his life
but if i ever
go more that side i make better
decisions i think today
if there's ever been a time the country
that was founded
on the right belief system who ends up
beating everyone in only 200 years
against empires that have been around
for a few thousand years maybe this
country has been blessed and maybe we
need to kind of go back a little bit and
say what was the reasoning was it us
was there something else that was on our
side i don't know i would say this and
and this is where uh i would agree with
the kind of uh judeo-christian framework
that you guys talked about before right
um i don't think that the quote unquote
atheist today
doesn't believe in a higher power i
think government is their higher power i
think that they believe in the system
the socialist system as their
judeo-christian framework i believe
that this especially this this nouveau
democratic socialist this isn't politics
to them this is religion to them and i
think part of the the argument that
we've had over the course of the last 10
years is you just talked about
intellectual versus emotional
politics is an intellectual conversation
there's there's ebb and there's flow
there's times where you need liberalism
and there's times where you need concern
no question there's you know i i always
try to think in a binary system you know
you like to say two wings are the same
burn i think of the democrats as the gas
pedal and the republicans as the break
you need gas to move forward you need a
break or you're gonna fall off the cliff
right so
i where i think we've gone awry in our
country in the last 10 years and i think
it's coming from the outside world
specifically hammering us uh is
this
kind of global communism this this
democratic socialism this is religion to
people for all the same ways i even said
this to you guys last night where you
guys are saying all right well you got
to think of your neighbor you need to
think of someone bigger than yourself
you have to provide i'm like this is
what i hear from socialists all the time
this is this is social justice rhetoric
you know this is the stuff that they are
all the time saying the people at the
top have too much the people at the
bottom need to be taken care of you got
to think of somebody other than yourself
i'm like this is socialist rhetoric and
then you made a great point what is the
difference
there is one key difference and there's
one difference that separates everything
and that is force force
force yeah i have the choice you know
you don't have to pray i'm cool with
that right you don't have to give money
i'm cool with that it's a choice how
many times have i gone to church and not
given anything hundreds of times like
one oh my gosh what a sinner i'm telling
you the truth what do you want me to
tell you i didn't give anything that day
i went to chuck i've gone to church so
many times
there's a great irish joke about that
you ever hear the irish catholic joker
but the point is i still walked out
there was a choice yeah
did you really
old patty mcdougal old maddie mcdougall
goes in and he says uh forgive me father
it's uh i have sinned it's been it's
been seven days since my last confession
well what would you do patty well you
know i lusted over over me neighbor's
wife
said well did you
did you do anything no but i thought
about it i thought about it a lot and i
thought about it constantly well you
know thinking about it is just as bad as
doing it my son so i'm gonna need you to
repent i repent and we're gonna need
penance what do i need to do father
seven hail mary's and put ten quid in
the box on your way out to to show god
you mean it so he says this hail mary's
and then he goes to the to the donation
box takes the quit out and he holds it
over the top and then puts it back in
his pocket and walks and the pastor goes
out he goes whoa whoa patty what what
happened what i i thought you you were
repenting he goes
well father i listened to your words and
i thought about it
and that's just as bad as doing it so i
figured okay
you know it's crazy the the the for me
for years we followed the rhetoric which
is what which is
never talk politics never talk religion
never talk this kind of stuff and this
is what we're talking about doing it all
today if you don't like it this ain't a
podcast for you i guarantee you but if
you'll like it smash that subscribe
button put a thumbs up to help us out
with the algorithms because we've got a
few more topics to go in the next 30
minutes let me give you one more thing
here we go folks everybody pay attention
turn off the computer tell your kids to
be quiet adam's got some thoughts for us
i just i'd be remiss if i didn't just
bring up i'm thinking you're going to
pray for all of us well it does involve
prayer okay
i think
you know prayer or affirmation or
meditation or thinking of others is
important
okay no doubt and i think
you know whether they say hey take a
second moment of silence that's great
but the whole
blanket
we had an issue thoughts and prayers hey
can you get your thoughts and prayers
out there today hey i you know my dad's
sick really could use your thoughts and
prayers hey we just had another gun
tragedy thoughts and prayers
at the end of the day thoughts and
prayers don't do [ __ ]
they don't solve problems if they don't
mean anything well that's what i'm
saying like the old thoughts and prayers
thing i'm just so sick of the thoughts
and prayers things are you sick of
virtue signaling or you think of praying
the virtue signaling but i'm not i'm
it's not been getting political it's
just the hey thoughts and prayers
thought oh we just had another 50 people
guy from a uh gun violence we really
could use that's just no it's just like
when i have friends from uh the uk right
so like i i you know travel and you know
i have a couple buddies out in
birmingham england right so they'll say
why is it that you guys always say have
a nice day
he's like you guys don't mean that [ __ ]
one bit yeah have a nice day just have a
nice day it's just a saying so i totally
agree with what you're saying i mean at
the end of the day we got to say what we
mean
and i know you want to move on pap but
one thing that i i did want to ask you
about this man is i mean you've talked
about this a lot i mean it's it's
interesting that you want uh
increased religion increased
accountability but you grew up in an
environment where you know religion gone
awry completely turned your world upside
down yeah but it was force
again it goes back to force
my kids everything is a choice
hey
you don't have to read today
it's the currency of the house but i
don't have to let you watch tv today but
you don't have to ever read in my house
but i don't have to ever let you watch
tv in our house it's a choice
hey you don't have to clean your bed
believe me buddy like i tell my son you
know you don't need to who said you need
to clean your bed nobody said you need
to clean your bed but i don't need to
let you play ipad this weekend it's a
choice there's always a choice right i'm
still going to love you you're still
going to be my son i'm still going to
take care of you but i'm sorry video
games don't come if you don't do your
part i got to do my part life is tough i
gotta do so the fourth part is the
problem in countries like iran because
you don't have the choice hey you want
to cover your hair no problem do it you
don't no problem do it that was asha's
way you want to cover yourself go
forward
some people want to wear like you know
show everything cleavage and they want
to have the shirt hide and show their
belly button because it's pierced and
wear skimpy what do you call it uh
skirts guess what i'm sure you support
that you know i'm sure you're vehement
now somebody who's extremely attractive
doesn't want to show any of it she only
wants to show the show to her man so
every time you see her you're like she's
dropped that gorgeous but i have no clue
because she's always covered up that's
her choice great she wants somebody goes
to the beach they wear a two-piece and
they got a thong on okay now that's kind
of weird but i like it let's just say
you like it some people go there they
don't want to wear that it's a choice
the force is the problem is when the
problem becomes a little bit problematic
for me so but to go back to what you
just said
and i've heard that a million times hey
david can you grab somebody to grab a
charger for my ipad please my ipad just
that if you guys got it i wouldn't mind
it here's what i will say about what you
just said okay
um
i
partially agree and i partially disagree
let me explain
uh who have i
who have i known longer you or tom
uh tom okay
who gave ten thousand dollars to obama
and trump and uh said committed to i'm
gonna give ten thousand dollars for this
to happen your boy sauce who else here
gave that
i don't know
but who here supports for that to become
a reality
everyone did mario give anything
not that mario aguilar no not him mario
didn't give anything yeah but does mario
want to support me doing the interview
to see uh bush and obama and trump be in
the same room of course i think that
there's a levels to support some go
above and beyond some people all they
can do is say dude i'm just going to
pray for you i got nothing else to give
you what do you want to do
my thoughts and prayers go for you right
some say hey i'm not only going to pray
for you i'm going to make a phone call
to see if i can get a guy to support you
hey not only am i going to pray for you
i'm going to make a phone call but i'm
also going to come out to your place to
help you out whatever you need i got you
some say thoughts and prayers some say
call a friend some come
and some go and give 50 000 or 10 000 so
there's levels i don't mind it as long
as the effort is to give something if
you want to give time to pray for me
that's a starter there's levels in life
you know hey if somebody works at a
company not everybody's going to be a
c-suite executive somebody may come here
and make sure the place is clean you're
contributing to society somebody wants
to come in here and edit fantastic
somebody wants a new cut great somebody
wants to grab i don't as long as we're
contributing the part about prayer is
the is the barrier to enter is just to
pray go for it there's no expectation
that's much better than a guy says screw
you i don't care what happens to this
guy so it's a way to at least get people
started i hear you on that there's
levels to this so but imagine you're
raising you're trying to you you pledged
five million dollars right yep and yeah
aaron zingerman called in he gave a half
a million i gave ten thousand yep this
person this person that's great imagine
if you were trying to raise a hundred
million dollars okay hypothetically
and all you got was a million people
giving you their thoughts and prayers
and my point is this it's just empty
it's just thoughts and prayers i think
how many people give you a thoughts and
prayers and literally don't think or
pray they just write that down and move
on with their life but guess who guess
who guess who's responsible for that
that's that's on everybody that's that's
their character though that's their
character that's their character their
health response it only hurts one person
it's themselves
you know my problem is if there's
actually something that needs to get
done whether
pick a pick a pick health care pick gun
violence yeah pick
a green new whatever it is
and then just thoughts and prayers it
doesn't get things done
yeah and i leave it on you that's fine
i'm just saying that i need something
more if you're looking to raise money
i'm just saying if i'm looking to raise
money for a cause yeah and all you're
hitting me with is a million people give
me thoughts and prayers buddy i need
someone i need some i need actual money
i need actual help i need you to buy i
know what you're saying i think what
you're saying there's just an easy way
out it's a big side of it it's fake yeah
there are people there are some that
will do it through fake looks just for
social yeah i i fully get that anyways i
agree and i had my own uh perspective on
that but uh it is what it is so let's
talk about work ethic that's how i work
have you ever heard elon musk
china and tom brady in the same story
it's kind of weird ain't it it's a
little bit of weirdness going on there
but let's try to see if we can pull this
off so
elon musk shows the new robot
and then says we definitely need
universal basic income it's eventually
going to happen this is based on the new
tesla bot
during the recent presentation on
artificial on ai hosted by tesla musk
said he is working on creating a tesla
about a robot that would do dangerous
repetitive and boring tasks so humans
don't have to but musk recognized that
the creation of this robot might take
place of the jobs that are people
currently getting paid for which is why
he said a guaranteed income will likely
be necessary in the future essentially
in the future physical work will be a
choice this is why i think long term
there will need to be universal basic
income okay so that's musk and he's
talked about this before this is not the
first time he's talked about this he
talked about this when uh andrew yanks
started talking about the the the
thousand dollars to everybody the ubi
and it must kind of support it as well
right just to be clear elon musk is a
ubi guy elon musk is a ubi guy and by
the way his argument is a valid argument
because he thinks technology is going to
advance human beings okay when you're
the person that's creating all this
technology you better be a ubi guy
because you're going to put millions of
people out of work fyi he also becomes
the most dangerous man in the world if
he does that just so you know because
essentially if you create these robots
to be that smart eventually robots take
control of you if you create them
everything he's doing with the neural
link and just thinking you have some
theories about that you think he wants
to you know i think he likes to bang
aliens i think i mean you've said that
maybe once or twice before maybe more to
look at his girl all right so then let's
watch
chinese authorities say
overtime star trek 996 policy is illegal
this is a reuters story chinese
authorities say over time 996 policy is
illegal 996 is
you know you're working nine to nine six
days a week chinese supreme court said
overtime practice of 996 working 996 pm
days is illegal taking aim at the
controversial policy that is common
amongst many chinese technology firms
working such hours has become a badge of
honor for some chinese companies and
employees silicon valley heavyweights
such as sukhoi capitals and mike moritz
have highlighted it as a competitive
advantage the country has over united
states chinese tech giants including
tick-tock owner
bite dance have in recent months been
walking back with their grueling work
hours including the big week small week
policy that requires workers to
alternate five day work weeks and six
day work weeks so that's china going
away from the six stairs right and
sequoia capital saying they have an edge
over us and then that leads to the brady
story okay so we got musk we got china
we got brady story tom brady disavows
today's work ethic it's not how to live
a joyful life fox news story brady has
some advice on how to be successful stop
blaming everyone else life is about
always changing and adapting on
different things today the world wants
to blame and shame and guilt and fear
everything all the time
we would never teach our kids that you
know we would never say this is how
you're going to get through life the
best you're going to blame everyone when
things don't go right brady called the
sport the ultimate blame game general
managers head coaches players
quarterbacks receivers defense offense
it's so easy to blame someone else it's
so hard to say i didn't get the job done
and we collectively didn't get the job
done that's the best part about team
sports i picked a team where everybody's
like hey we got to get better it's not
like i got all the answers you just
you guys just all screwed it up except
me exact opposite way to play the game
you know you got to play together so
that's what he's saying man he's saying
if you want to make it at that level it
sucks it's not the way to live and don't
blame people so
what are your thoughts about the future
of hard work what's going to happen
phil you want to start this one off oh
my gosh um i mean look
being a bodybuilder
you're your own first responder in
everything you do
i gotta get up in the morning
even if i have sheree wake me up i still
gotta move
i still gotta eat that food i still
gotta get on that treadmill this morning
i was like gosh i haven't trained legs
in like a month and i'm going to go do
it i didn't want to do it but i tried to
you know i live by my own accord i say
live life like leg day
and that means like it's going to hurt
you have fear and anxiety or whatever
but you know what there's a reward and
that reward isn't for everybody else
that reward is for me
so i have a dream of like what i want to
do and i'm like look i'm going to do
this and here's the best part about
being a bodybuilder that if i eat right
i get results if i train right i get
results
practice does not make perfect because i
can practice a lot of freaking bad
habits so i got to be a student of
myself and i have to evolve
throughout my life because what i did in
my 20s i damn sure couldn't do in my 30s
and i'm 41 now and i'm learning a lot
and i'm scratching my head and i'm
thinking
oh my gosh
if i could apply what i know now
to the 20 year old phil heath holy
smokes but that's life and it has no
rehearsal whatsoever but
you know what i can't blame a coach
even if i decided you know i work with
honey rambod right
brilliant coach
i lost the olympia in 2018 and in 2020
right
i could literally
point at him and say you know what we
didn't do this right you didn't tell me
this who hired him i did
so you know like the level of
accountability i mean people have to
really start asking themselves are they
holding themselves accountable don't
always look for someone else to do it
man you're making your choices and like
pat said no one's forcing me to compete
either
no one's forcing me to do this podcast
no one's forcing me to do [ __ ]
there are two things the two c's i teach
kids and stuff
choices and consequences you got to know
the damn difference and if you don't
life is going to teach your ass and it's
going to be a very difficult lesson you
just have to pray to god that it's going
to be a very inexpensive lesson because
if not it's going to be a truly
expensive lesson like we saw at the
beginning of this show
is that those are expensive lessons for
you not understanding your choices
in this life
that's where i'm at with this what do
you think about that adam so you got you
got
great feedback obviously you're talking
about seven times a stroll olympia and
for bodybuilders uh uh you're being
judged for every single piece of muscle
every
fiber everything that you got going on
right
so for you
musk says we're going to ubi no matter
what china 996. brady
it's not how to live a joyful life by
blaming everybody take responsibility
who's right
well i think at the end of the day why
do humans work
right obviously the easy answer is like
well i gotta get [ __ ] done but i think
work gives you meaning and purpose to
your life and like i look it's funny
because all i'm sure the people with
pets out there
you know have the same thing you walk
out your door and i see my two cats i'm
like
enjoy your day you two like doing
nothing
right you know you got your dogs all
right just be a dog
so dogs do dog things and cats do cats
things and humans do human things what
do humans do humans need to work work
gives you meaning and purpose and
community and friendship
and everything that that comes
associated with work
and improvement like
when you like the picture of you and
when you're in denver playing point
guard or whatever it's a different
fill
um
imagine if you just
like
obviously with baseball and everything
you did with mma and everything and
everything that imagine if you pat never
put in the work to be where you are
today you were just that 22 year old
still at bally's ah whatever i don't
need to work that hard
i think
there was a what was the poll out here
that survey shows that no that people no
longer believe working hard would lead
to a better life
i want to know who actually
took that survey and took that poll
who's raising these freaking kids that's
my biggest question i i can tell you
there are people that i know in the
entertainment industry specifically that
feel that way because they do put in
crazy amounts of hours and they do put
in their all their art and their
intellectual property to being a
comedian they're sleeping on couches and
they're sleeping
capitalism is phenomenal for most things
everybody here knows that i'm a free
market guy capitalism does art pretty
poorly that's one of the things
education and art we don't we don't do
well with capitalism all right so there
are people in there and they are
talented and they're working very very
hard and they're getting nothing out of
it then they have to do a job now where
ubi comes in is it's it's necessary to
stop
you know revolution ubi is going to
become necessary because if you have
somebody you talk about before somebody
that's a janitor or somebody that maybe
tried to make it as a singer or
something like that got uh got a girl
pregnant got got a guy pregnant got
pregnant by a guy whatever it is and
then necessity had to take over now they
had to take the first job that they
could and they are you know a janitor
they're driving uber they're well i was
when i was shut down in uh non-essential
not a central tattoo i went from two
national tours i was on two national
tours two years ago to driving uber and
working construction because only only
two jobs i can get during the pandemic
there was only two essential jobs i
could do i couldn't tell jokes i
couldn't go on tour everybody was gonna
get sick but i could work construction
and i could drive uber
as mad as i was at the world for having
to do that if i didn't have that
available if robots had that job and i
was just sitting there with my credit
evaporating and and my savings
evaporating i i would have gone insane
so if you have people that are taking
jobs that they don't want just to
survive and they're already kind of
skeptical about the system as it is
right or they they feel skeptical about
the system and maybe they are working
hard but they're working hard in low
wages where they don't see any way to
move forward there's only so much money
you can make work as a waitress or a
bartender and it's not like they're not
working hard
now if a robot does that which in
australia i'm sure you've traveled the
world patrick's travel the world you
guys have seen this in airports where
now they don't even have bartenders in
some of these places you get a cup and
the cup has a false bottom and you put
it on you put your credit card in and
you put the cup on and it fills the beer
from the bottom it's not even a
bartender you don't you don't tip the
machine so well gee give me give me
so are you a believer in ubi or no dude
honestly i wasn't and i'm coming around
to it because i think it's a necessity
not in this moment andrew yang is early
on 20 years down the road i think it's a
necessity 20 years down the road give me
give me like we've seen what happened
during cove
two-thirds of people staying home are
getting paid more to stay home than they
were in their job
they're collecting ubi i'm a millionaire
what are people doing with their lives
if you're just getting paid to stay home
what are people doing i don't think that
that's what ubi really is i think ubi is
supposed to be
that basic needs are met and i don't
know the math behind it so well i'm not
necessarily sold on it but
i think it's something that has to be
taken seriously and it's something that
needs to be
uh researched as much as possible and i
know that this goes this is a seeming
contradiction to my worldview but
again i just think that we're going to
run into a situation where if you have
10 15 20 30 unemployment worldwide you
have a nightmare situation unless you
are gonna have a global economy where
there it's going to be cheaper to have
labor and you can go be a construction
worker in africa then you know you can
you can like when i look at uh you know
elon musk and jeff bezos going to space
i don't think about space i think about
international travel in two hours i
think about them going to the upper
atmosphere and then coming back down in
johannesburg and that could be your
morning commute like that's what i think
like if we're going to have a global
economy uh i i don't know man i think
the world in 50 years is going to be so
different than the world we have today
it's going to be incomprehensible for us
to understand how we didn't function in
those ways pd what was the name of the
guy
that he said i got 10 billion dollars
richer during the pandemic and the
question was does the money flow up does
it flow down yeah what was that story
because i feel like that's where the
money's gonna end up with the rich
anyway unfortunately what we can say
everything we want about ubi uh people
if you don't change their habits
internally they're going to keep
spending the money money's going to go
to the rich it doesn't matter what you
do you give money to ubi oh we need
universal basic income just think the
money's going to the top billionaires
just think about it that way like it's
going to go through here to the
billionaire so this whole universal
basic income is money to the rich great
go do it it's going to flow to the rich
no matter what you do now on the uh
argument about uh robots taking over all
this other stuff great so do we know do
we not know this whole thing about
robots been talked about for a long time
uh education is gonna have to change the
approach to schooling is going to have
to change the approach to what jobs you
go get is going to change uh in a
if you live in bermuda you know what's
the number one job kids go get what
degree they get what is the number one
job kids go get in bermuda can you guess
what it is yeah which one has to do with
hospitality math actually actually yeah
because the five reinsurance companies
are in bermuda so when is the last time
you thought about getting a degree in
actuary you don't well in bermuda you do
because you want to go and come back and
work for one of the five actuary
companies so you have to shift the way
you go get a degree if you work in a
place where the biggest employer is
forward and you have to kind of think
about hey i don't want to leave this
place i want to be in detroit great
you're going to go and come back let's
just say you're going to get that job if
you're living in a place where you're in
silicon valley everybody wants to hire a
predictive analytics or an engineer
guess what you're probably going to go
do right if you're living in texas in a
farm place you know raising cattle and
that you're probably going to go do that
it all so we'll pivot we'll adjust
people will be pivoting and adjusting
but money is always going to flow to the
people with the best habits i don't care
what anybody says money is always going
to flow to the people with the best
habits this thing about china's 996
i hate to say this to you but it's kind
of impressive the fact that china's
doing this they're they're 100 years
behind us
you know the us
they did this with ford because uh
back in the days the average human
worker was working 69 hours a week it
was 69 hours a week that we worked the
average american worker used to work
69 hours a week today the numbers around
39 hours a week right give or take right
versus 69 hours now here's the thing
with me
i have worked 996 for nearly 20 years
but it's by choice
i have worked 996 by choice for 20 years
these guys work 996 by force there's a
big difference i don't know a single
billionaire that you meet
who doesn't have a
you know 8 10 6 for 10 years or 20 years
that is a proven formula if you want to
make it to the high level you got to
really light it up for a good good run
that you go on you got to go on that one
run of yours right so this is mandatory
for everybody that wants to kill it in
their space you need the rest you need
all that stuff but that's that and then
the last part about uh people no longer
believing
you know working hard will lead to a
better life really okay let's unpack
that people no longer believe let's put
a funnel put a funnel there right what's
the funnel the funnel is a kid is born
the first five years the kids influenced
by who
who's the kid influenced my parents and
then from five years old he goes to
kindergarten he's influenced by who
friends okay
first to 12 years old they're influenced
by who teachers teachers do teachers
what percentage of teachers love
capitalism
10 percent 20
30 percent i don't know
then go to college you go to college for
four years you tell me what percentage
of professors in college love capitalism
today tell me how many of them i just
interviewed the communist professor in
riverside community college like the guy
had a great conversation with him he
fully believes the two of the greatest
leaders that help society the most are
stalin and mao he wasn't joking he was
100 firm about it i asked him if a 22
year old kid has a decision today to be
the next jeff bezos create 1.3 million
jobs or be the next stalin what is
better for the world he says it's not
even close stalin if he becomes the next
stalin revolution it's better for the
world this guy fully believes it and
he's not 22 he's 45 years old our age
talking something like that right that
guy's 45
mid 40s the beard makes them look like
145 but the point is this when people
say things like
you know uh surveys show people no
longer believe working hard will lead to
a better life it's not it should say
professors
yeah encourage kids to no longer believe
that working card you got to change the
wording to that title or you could say
you could work smart not hard or maybe
you could do both but the fact that you
just don't want to work hard give me
this bs about working hard doesn't you
you got to
in order to be competitive are you
kidding me pat just illustrated it
perfectly when i when i got into
bodybuilding october 8 2002 i said i
want to be a bodybuilder
i recognized that i was at a
disadvantage
because i was going to go against people
that have been doing lifting weights
since they were 12 years old now i
wasn't one of those guys but yet i did
have the genetics right when i turned
pro the gift
when i turned pro 16 years ago
everything reset
i was a pro i was 25 years old and i'm
going against the best in the world and
i'm thinking i gotta outwork them i
gotta outsmart them but it's gonna take
time
okay
i didn't do the olympia my first two
years of being a pro in 06 and 07 even
though i qualified why because i was
like i need more stage time so i got on
the road i did numerous appearances to
get my stage presence up i knew nothing
about that i had no coach that taught me
those things
i did everything in my power to make
sure what i can increase my capacity at
a faster rate than everybody else so i
can equal the playing field eventually
i'm gonna catch their ass
and guys like dexter you can ask him he
said eventually this kid is going to win
because i i knew
that i had to do what i couldn't train
just one time a week i had to train
twice a day twice a week but then i was
like well i'm going to burn out
everybody's like over training this and
that well massage therapist acupuncture
infrared sauna hyperbaric whatever it is
instead of buying [ __ ] i went out
and spent money on those modalities that
increased my capacity so then eventually
when i got there i was i would arrive
and then oh wait i did my first olympia
got third
the rest is history
i was able to dominate during that time
period because i had already made those
other years profitable so then when
opportunity met i was like
let's go but
eight billion people in the world only
four have one mr olympia seven times
okay that's all you're gonna do right
yeah so people have what do you say by
the way out work out work out improve
out strategize and the scariest one
outlast outlast it's the most
intimidating thing the most intimidating
thing in the world of competition the
fact that you i tell you i used to tell
my competitors
you can beat me one day maybe a week
maybe a month yeah you'll match my work
ethic for a year i will guarantee you
you're going to slow down i'm not
i said you're going to how many years
are you going to go i'm going to go five
years straight i'm going to beat you
i'ma go 10 years you're not going to
last
so that's the mindset that's
intimidating but let's let's transition
because we got four more stories i'd
like to get to we only have 13 minutes
so let's see what we can do here on uh
rapid fire with some of these stories
okay
australia created a police state to stop
covet data shows it's not working
um i'm getting more videos are you you
guys i'm sure you guys are seeing
obviously what's going on over there
on monday new zealand prime minister
uh
jacinda arden announced the government
would be extending this lockdown
following an outbreak the delta varia we
don't yet believe that we have reached a
peak of outbreak or necessarily the edge
of it arden said at a news conference
meanwhile in nearby australia residents
are entering the ninth week of lockdown
that had initially been scheduled for
two weeks and many of the hardest hits
parts of the city nbc reports military
personnel roam the streets and
authorities issue fines up to thousand
seven hundred dollars to individuals
breaking lockdown orders economists at
the rand corporation and the university
of southern california reached a similar
conclusion regarding the effectiveness
of shelter in place order months later
we failed to find that shelter-in-place
policy saved the lives the author
reports we failed to find that countries
or u.s states that implemented sip
policies statements stay in place
policies earlier in which the sip
policies had no longer to operate had
slower excess death than other countries
u.s states that's slower to implement
sip policies anyways it's craziness kids
are out there by the beach they're
getting fined a thousand dollar fines
for their parents did you see that the
the manhunt they had for those kids yeah
the one guy that was on two helicopters
like one guy was in the elevator and
they said watch this man cough twice
three times if you see this man report
him to us nation
manhunt this guy left the house for me
to get our australian friend on the
phone real quick is he time
do we have the phone to call them or no
i think this is okay call them up let's
see if we got
even if we get a couple minutes from
this guy in australia i told him we
would be fine
there's people that are that are in
their backyards getting the cops called
on them because they went into their
backyard and they didn't have their
masks
in their own backyard who's snitching
it's insanity bro like you snitching no
you know what i'm saying
you know who it is don't put on you know
who it is i'm going to all my neighbors
i'm like
you snitched on me boy
so this is connected is this how does
this work
there you go oh wow he's out of the
country there's two rings
he isn't he's in australia
he thought you were literally
i thought he his name
australia kansas
he's an american who's been living in
australia for kangaroo sleep it's
delicious tomorrow already midnight
he really is stand by if you've ever
eaten kangaroos i got two numbers but
this one doesn't work lean meat baby
seven times you're still waiting hang on
different number let's see again oh my
gosh
this guy let the phone ring seven times
adam
um more round
no no one more time one more time one
four the guy's going through enough
already he's out he's out
australia
thoughts what time is it what's he
telling you when you talk to him
right now poor guy's getting arrested
right now
he's getting arrested
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the next
story jake paul
passes test test with the split decision
victory over tyrone woodley did anybody
see the fight here no i watched it i
watched it do you watch it yeah what'd
you think about it
were you impressed with him
uh no
he wasn't you were not impressed with
them no not at all what'd you think
i think uh
look tyron woodley's a is a beast yeah
so i think jake paul is uh by the way do
you think that was fixed any of it yeah
any of it any of it any of it any of it
no david said
i think he's fighting guys that are i
mean tyron woodley's maybe five eight
jake paul's not a small dude no we saw
him yeah when we were leaving the party
that one night he's six one legit strong
guy he's i mean his brother's an
absolute beast
can we admit that the match-ups that
we're seeing yeah aren't like i mean
exactly when he fights a real boxer i
think he's gonna get his [ __ ] but for
now but pat you brought up a good point
even though i didn't watch it
he's in shape the god when he's round
he's unable to move man yeah and then
that that's no joke like if you've ever
like put gloves on harder hardest it is
tough here's the thing here's my
perspective on why it was fixed tell us
first they didn't beat each other up
really yeah so the whole thing was
eight rounds i'll prove that i can box
an entire eight rounds and then i'll
move up because if jake paul loses then
well let me ask there was one part that
was sus where woodley rocked them had
him up yeah literally on the road but
here's the question finish him off david
profile question for you have you seen
woodley's last five fights
no i'm not have you seen how woodley
fights i know he's a striker but no have
you ever seen this phrase you've seen
dana white's biggest frustration with
woodley's passes yeah he's not
aggressive he's passive so ty dana white
said this guy could be the face of ufc
okay but he's passive he doesn't fight
he plays like point game that's how he
wins fights that's not how you sell out
a crowd so nobody wants to see the the
guy be like that so he typically fights
like that that is his strategy that's
how he's fought but to me
i've never
said anything positive about jake paul's
uh boxing uh uh
you know abilities it's always the fact
that these guys are great at getting
attention they're fantastic at what
they're doing i was impressed the fact
that this guy could hang for eight
rounds are you kidding me for 190 pound
guy
six one to be able to last eight rounds
it was impressive jake paul lebron james
machine machine gun kelly baker mayfield
odell beck all of the most annoying
people in our zeitgeist they're all
centered in one place cleveland ohio the
mistake by the malays
did a great show there last year there
was multiple people on the meet and
greet line that had teeth whittled down
to spikes
and face tattoos
this is it's come we've come a long way
from drew carey cleveland ohio boy this
is ohio's saying like you're thinking
about moving there oh man what you're
saying yeah you got a feeling he likes
that uh it it the the actual uh the the
bay catches on fire by the way do you
know why it's called the mistake by the
by the male lake cleveland because they
spelt it wrong there's an extra e that
shouldn't be there cleveland uh yeah so
anyway there's a little tasty tip
there's the value for you
how much longer are people just going to
tune into this jake paul nonsense
long as he wants like he wins but
nobody's nobody's watching to watch him
win people are watching to get his
watches out there is a community that's
supporting this but they're oh you're
sure they're supporting
80 percent of the people like most of
the ufc wants to see him get knocked out
yeah most and by the way woodley is the
better fighter yeah woodley just didn't
capitalize on the opportunity that he
had and secondly yeah if the referee
would have done his job right that's a
knock down yeah yeah he knocked them out
there yeah so that's one night so that
needed to be recorded but they didn't do
it that's extra point it would have been
10 8 rounds still wouldn't made a
difference two rounds one of the things
that he did right is
an old uh strategy from uh purnell
whitaker maybe no sugar ray
whitaker the last 10 seconds he knew how
to score points yeah jake went and
scored points the last 15-20 seconds
that's what he did he was behind it
and that's the last thing
the referees not the referees the judges
remember is the last and you know but
woodley should have won the fight yeah
what happened after like so i saw a clip
tattoo yeah what's up with that he's the
king of the [ __ ] boys yeah i mean that's
his whole appeal you know jake announced
yesterday he retired oh i know right
you usada probably came in you started
she's like oh i'm retired is there any
chance that i wouldn't get this
oh yeah no no no no no no i will not be
paying attention i am
i think he's not gonna do it to piss him
off i don't think jake's gonna do the
rematch because i don't think anybody
cares to see those two fighters
uh fury little brother fury
oh tommy yeah mommy fury 23. uh that's
flirting yeah i hear everybody talking
about that
but i mean the last name fury you do not
want to box with a guy with a last name
fury oh yeah they have issues the the
gypsies
destroy you is what they is that his
brother half brother what is that guy
little brother
brother yeah
little bro by the way okay delta delta
airlines you guys heard about what delta
did if you're looking for a job they're
hiring
delta airlines announced
that it's raising health insurance
premiums for unvaccinated employees by
200 a month to cover higher covet costs
so
so if you don't if you didn't take the
vaccine
they're raising the 200. the delta
airlines ceo ed bastain notified
employees wednesday that they will face
a 200 monthly increases on their health
insurance premium start november 1st if
they are unvaccinated against covet 19
citing steep cost to cover employees who
are hospitalized with the virus
unvaccinated employees will face
other restrictions including indoor
masking effective immediately weekly
cover 19 tests starting september 12 the
measures are the latest attempt by u.s
corporation to drive up cover
vaccination raise delta stop short of an
outright mandate like the rival united
airlines established earlier this month
the average hospital stay for kobe 19
has cost delta
50 000 per person best thing set in an
employee memo this surge surcharge will
be necessary to address the financial
risk the decision to not vaccinate is
creating for our company yeah
this terrifies me as a fat guy i got to
tell you the fact that they could turn
around and say oh well listen man you
had a cheeseburger last week and your
bmi i don't know it's higher health
risks here i mean this is insane this is
crazy can you imagine any other scenario
where somebody was able to charge you
more for being some shade of unhealthy
can you imagine any scenario where you
could restrict access to to public goods
and services because well you know
you're some shade of unhealthy i don't
know what to tell you i don't know man
you are looking better these days so
something tells me that your premiums
are going to go down and fly america and
let's move on to the next well the
problem is
we're never
we i've seen these topics and stuff and
where are we talking about health health
and wellness yeah
we just don't
none of this [ __ ] is on twitter facebook
whatever they're right
but they're just not saying it
they're not they're not encouraging
their employees to go to the gym they're
not encouraging hey flight attendants
when you're when you check in real late
with these hotels make sure like they do
have a uh you know facility in there for
you to do your cardio or something hey
we have some healthier eating options
and stuff like that hey we have you know
some immune booster pills or whatever it
is they're not talking about this but
why is imagine being standing online for
a club in miami adam wants to get in but
they got a blockchain of everybody
you've been with and it's like sorry
adam you were exposed they probably
should
they probably should do this you know
sorry
south beach they probably shouldn't
sorry sorry you've been you've been
exposed to stds
nice club with your dennis rodman jersey
on bro they're like sorry about it
from boston and joining me
not one but two so it anyway but what
i'm saying is that this come on what
where what
what do we stop what are we stopping man
what are we stopping for kobe what are
we stopping here how
what are you talking about man like
they're only talking about that they're
not talking about heart disease
everything else well your father your
father had heart issues right you
imagine that they're like well sorry
patrick we'd love to sell you this
ducati but you have a history of heart
disease in your family and i think you
conk out at any second can't have you on
the road go on 110 buddy so i'm gonna
have to give you this uh this uh
over here i gotta give you this vest for
pat is that okay that's what you that's
what you medically qualified for
it's insanity no that's how fast you
went was that how 167 or us yeah no we
went 165. insane hell yeah yeah we won
165 in a bentley that's crazy at in the
405 freeway insane which by the way i
actually don't feel like it but this is
why all this stuff is car insurance
premiums should be higher
85 year old with florida plates driving
35. like this stuff doesn't work bro
when i drive here on one in the morning
oh man it could be 15 minutes it could
be 35 minutes depending on who's on the
left we're at greenwich we're walking in
and
the guy comes up and everyone's wearing
a mask and i said listen we are from
florida we have no idea what's going on
what's the situation here with mask he
says no you know you can wear it but
look you guys are vaccinated you're fine
he has no clue we're vaccinated he says
look you guys are here i know you guys
are vaccinated you're fine right right
okay cool sounds good
like i didn't get it
that's good very weird what happens yeah
just go ahead and go in and we went to
the other restaurant the girl's like uh
you don't have a mask on please put your
masks on i said you're the first person
i made us wear masks yeah i don't like
this stuff either you should see what
they're doing in new york i said yeah i
know that's why we live in florida just
so you know
okay
and then we went and had our breakfast
with isaiah thomas and tom thibodeau
sitting right next to us nice
the only uh michael jordan's best friend
the the og
my hero i forgot this is yeah that's
isaiah thomas that says here are you
kidding me yeah how far was he sitting
like and this is a sink i tell sam i'm
like this guy is sitting next to us his
name is isaiah thomas sam goes like this
like what are you doing bro don't be
like looking at him for like two minutes
i'm like what is the matter with you
don't be weird don't be weird don't be
aware
little did
anyway before we go yo we got a big week
this week yes you want to set us up for
that vault we got the vault here cannot
wait to see everybody we're going to
have a
a packed house here uh it starts
tomorrow night with the ceo session
obviously we're going to have billy
being there we're going to have dustin
pottier which is he's a number one guy
right now well how did i hear it can i
see this gary kasparov will have um
who else am i missing out okay am i
missing somebody else billy bean billy
bean no phil heath will have there and
on top of that outside of phil heat no i
mean first thing that's always funny
how about this guy right here
at all i don't know maybe
minute confirmation great share from
oaktree capital management managing
director will be they'll be interviewing
him wow he's oaktree capital management
has 155 billion dollars of assets under
management we're going to talk about how
to raise money can i wait to see
everybody here in miami you're going to
see the entire camp here at the diplomat
and then we're doing an after party at
the house with a select few people let's
go by the way we were thinking about
having this uh this uh this you know the
ball with the girl that was going to be
dancing in it
very provocative and i'm like listen are
we doing that for in front of 100 people
it's kind of a little awkward dylan
comes at that what's that girl doing i
said dylan go to sleep
go to sleep
of course by the way folks if you're
listening
since we talked about it please pray for
this dog
please pray pray father
thoughts and prayers not the kind adam
talked about but the legitimacy [ __ ]
don't don't poor biz doc and uh kai did
say there may be some masseuse at the
left so having said that having a
wonderful week we will do this again
next week everybody take care bye
bye bye bye thanks guys
you